five days after the shooting down of the
Ukrainian airliner and the killing of
all 176 on board the first sign of
Iranian accountability in the weekly
briefing by ronk judiciary which was
also the first media conference since
the disaster confirmation of the first
arrests but no details on who they are
a vast investigation is underway and
many people have been questioned and
some people have been arrested the
investigation is still ongoing president
Hassan rouhani is describing the downing
of the Boeing 737 as an unforgivable
error it happened while Iranian air
defenses were on alert soon after the
firing of a barrage of missiles at a US
base in Iraq the Iranian leadership has
faced three days of protests for denying
involvement in the airliner attack as
international pressure grew the
Revolutionary Guard eventually admitted
on Saturday that the jet was shot down
by mistake
rouhani says anyone responsible will be
punished but no single person could be
blamed
this incident was without precedent in
the history of our country there has
never been a time when a person in
charge of our air defense systems or an
officer has committed such an error
against a passenger plane in the
country's capital and so close to the
international airport while sympathizing
with all the dear families that were hit
by this major tragedy I tell them that
we will continue this path until
discovering all the aspects of the
incident and punishing those involved
rouhani is also dealing with another
problem three European countries have
triggered a dispute process which could
mean more sanctions Britain France and
Germany say the Iranians aren't
complying with their commitment to the
2015 nuclear agreement to limit its
nuclear development the European
signatories to the deal have been
pressured to abandon it since the United
States withdrew in May of 2018
then reimpose sanctions to damage Iran's
oil dependent economy the Europeans say
triggering their dispute is not aimed at
reimposing UN sanctions day
of this mechanism is to resolve issues
relating to the implementation of the
agreement within the framework of the
Joint Commission I think it has to be
clear that the objective is therefore to
find solutions and return to full
compliance within the framework of this
Agreement Iran announced its latest step
to cutting its commitment to the deal by
lifting restrictions on uranium
enrichment earlier this month the latest
nuclear announcement won't do anything
to ease high tensions between Iran and
the United States following the u.s.
assassination of the head of iran's
potts force Qasem Soleimani in baghdad
two weeks ago Iran has warned it will
force all US troops out of the Middle
East at all costs iran's Foreign
Ministry says it will have a firm and
serious response to any destructive
measures taken by the remaining
signatories of the deal Iran finds
itself yet again on the defensive trying
to find the solution between the
disputes has with the remaining
signatories of the jcpoa because the
alternative could have far-reaching
ramifications throughout the Middle East
Dorset jabari al Jazeera Tehran